police in Indiana credit a phone tip for
helping toward a potential mass shooting
at a school the tip sent the tip rather
sent police racing to Dennis
Intermediate School in Richmond
yesterday officers exchanged gunfire
with a teenager before the teen killed
himself Dean Reynolds is outside that
school in Richmond Indiana with how this
incident began dean good morning good
morning more than 500 students in grades
5 through 8 were facing an
all-too-familiar threat but because
someone who saw something said something
no one other than the teenager with the
gun was shot police in Indiana are
trying to find out why a 14 year old
armed teen targeted Dennis middle school
in Richmond Indiana on Thursday did you
think your life was in danger yes and
actually I said it crying and I was
panicking and shaking
law enforcement received a 911 and
alerted school officials to lock down
the campus arriving officers found the
armed teen outside and when they
confronted him he shot his way into that
school door and the police raced in
right after him even as they shot at
them before killing himself students say
they hid with their teachers behind
locked classroom doors you could
literally hear the Ferren like the
principal's voice when she said lockdown
lockdown
Peggy Lewis lives across the street from
the middle school she says she spoke
with the suspects father after the
shooting he just said that his son took
all of his guns this morning and said if
in taking me was going to kill him too
because he was a juvenile investigators
are not releasing the shooters name or
the identity of the 911 caller who
tipped off police earlier this year the
FBI admitted it failed to follow up on a
tip it got 40 days before February
shooting at Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School in parkland Florida 17
students and staff died Indiana police
credit the tip they received with saving
lives so we had an idea of what was
about to happen and what we bought what
a person thought was about to happen
and that's what worked now even though
police say the suspect was not a student
here at the time of the incident the
people we spoke to say the suspect had
been bullied and they said his father
told them that his son had spoken of
seeking revenge John Dean Reynolds Thank
You Dean